d do you go in my room I'm sorry but
this is what I wanted to talk to you
about that
I know that you're a hoarder what I'm
sorry okay it's okay we love you we love
you and we just want to help okay I had
to go in your room because I smelled
what I thought could only be the scent
of death but then I later discovered it
was an unfinished everything makeup with
cream cheese which no judgment is way
worse luzhin finished and everything
bagel no I am NOT playing this little
game okay and don't go into my room
again no importa me more eating into
casa okay Tammy English porque tu que
necesito let the Toto make haste my
super tray will let me float down you
sack a tamale - que entra - guató arrow
policies when already too soon to know
using the same cheese crater and she's
using feet yeah okay let's dig in
welcome back okay but just so you know
it's not that I'm not mad about you
going into my room no cool very not
totally not cool I'm glad that you're
honoring your instincts and good for you
for setting boundaries I just want you
to explore your feelings in a
judgment-free zone okay this is a safe
space
well not literally safe how about we
start with looking at the most common
causes of hoarding and see if you
connect with any of them now I don't
want to put words in your mouth but
hoarding often develops as a coping
mechanism for a feeling of a lack of
control does that resonate with you well
obviously before I become a citizen you
know I was always so anxious about my
status and you know you feel this lack
of motivate powerless you know that's
when it started to all pile of yeah I'm
sorry to interrupt I'm still feeling
very uncomfortable in general and I'm
also straining to feel ill probably
because I've been eating cheese that's
mixed in with your heel skin
I'm so sorry that my emotions are making
you this uncomfortable I love you and
support you this is about
Alanna's feet one moment please Abby
relax I put the greater in barbicide
after I use it on my feet do you think
I'm an idiot
beside okay so what I'm sensing is that
the Horton provides a sense of comfort
in times of stress it's gotten a lot
worse lately I don't I don't know why
because I bet I really have been so
happy with you you know I often
encounter in my work people struggling
with the duality of relationships you
know maybe there's something about this
relationship even if it's going dope Lee
that's causing anxiety I'm sorry but I
want to drive to the hospital oh my god
okay
you are wasting Jaime's hour okay this
is so unprofessional
I'll handle it te quiero mucho que trae
la semaine poco de mio por que siento
que no es una mano como que perder
control verdad y siento que estaba
haciendo esto todo esto campano cosas
spooky mr. Katan de elastomer ami mismo
Acharya says Oh vodka pardon me oh no
Creek no madam it is hmm but I mean okay
case I'm going to say then I'll go to
him a mucho meal deeper dirty I mean I'm
yellow tambien cosas contigo okay sorry
no soda okay dude just eat honest with
me did I or did I not eat your foot
cheese what part of I put the cheese
grater in barbicide before it touches
the cheese do you not understand and not
for nothing
you're probably lactose inherent cuz
you're an Ashkenazi Jew or maybe get
another okay and have you never sucked
on a couple of those before I've sucked
on toe really yeah because you're lucky
girl a lot of people paid good money for
my foot shavings they do oh look at
these two am I good or am I good alright
that is about all the time we have for
this week actually we went a little bit
over but that's okay I want to thank you
for making me confirm my holiness
because it made me see that I was just
putting it as a barrier for
next step in our relationship that's the
best thing is Erebus get here ma'am what
I decided to move in with Johnny his
house in New Jersey I mean I don't like
to say crazy but you are nuts
okay move into Jersey where do you Bruce
Springsteen you're like so you don't
even know Bruce Springsteen why would
you move to Jersey baby listen you were
right I need to stop self sabotaging
myself now I need to take the next step
with my boyfriend I see one therapy
session now you're cured okay great not
a real therapy session please it wasn't
no classic denial you are mental bro I
wanna connect top 2% let me just start
your second over here okay if this is
about the foot cheese I swear to
god Abbi no listen dude I think you need
to take some of your own advice
you just told Jaime that his hoarding
problem was due to maybe a lack of
control right yeah I feel like that's
happening with you right now I mean him
moving out is a huge Jill and you're
trying to control him you have to let
him live his own life I said all that
huh
yeah you did hey you guys
fully sorry that was stupid not about me
I am so sorry you know this is right for
you guys and you know what I think I've
been scared because I have been feeling
like this was coming let's get it for me
too I haven't lived without you in such
a long time
but in a way it's super easy just
Montclair it's like across the pond you
know wait where's my clay here like
Montclair Montclair so where's this
Bruce big theater you know I don't
really know his music I don't know who
the boss is
hmm what does he sound like yeah
[Music]
baby right I I now get my yeah I guess
survive
[Music]